hi hi everyone thanks for coming yeah so
this talk is gonna be about how to
estimate stock price correlations using
Wikipedia let me start by telling you a
little bit about myself so I work for a
start-up in London
it's called gnosis I'm the chief data
scientist there and we are basically
analyzing Twitter data and helping
finance professionals get an
understanding of possible anomalies or
events or other kinds of interesting
information in Twitter before that I
obtained my PhD mixture of machine
learning and natural language processing
and now I want in this talk and
hopefully future talks find the middle
ground between finance and my previous
life let's say which was natural
language processing so this talk is
going to be about the combination of
unstructured data and finance and I've
also added a link to my website if you
need to know more or see more from my
previous life okay so as I said this
talk is gonna be about Wikipedia data
and how we can use Wikipedia data in
order to find in this case we're not
gonna make predictions but we are going
to look at correlations between data in
Wikipedia and I guess you guess what
stock prices okay so usually financial
data when you talk about financial data
we talk about pricing data this is this
kind of time series data is what finance
professionals are used to and
our optimizing their algorithms for
processing this particular time series
however there's also quite a lot of
sources of unstructured data out there
so people are looking at things like
annual reports which contain hints on
how the company was performing what kind
of future avenues they are looking at
then they're also quite a lot of broker
research there's also conference call
transcripts Investor Relations
presentations third party research news
and press releases and for bigger
companies bigger banks they also have
their own researchers come up with
in-house content so quite a lot of
unstructured data out there however
let's try something really crazy let's
try to see if there's any kind of signal
coming from unconventional data so when
I talk about unconventional data I'm
thinking about data sets that have been
created without having any financial
applications in mind so this can be
Wikipedia and its related project so
dbpedia is a structured version of
Wikipedia the same is valid for wiki
data also obtained we are peoples
collaboration then we can also look at
Twitter it turns out that Twitter is a
very interesting data source if we are
interested in for example what various
people what are the various people's
opinion regarding certain certain stock
or what kind of events are happening out
there in terms of mergers and
acquisitions and so on you can also look
at crime
based CrunchBase is a small knowledge
base that's very tailored towards tech
the technical domain specifically
smaller companies startups good so if
you talk about Wikipedia it's it's a
large project there's ten edits per
second the English Wikipedia currently
has over five million articles so that's
an average of 800 new articles per day
so that's a lot of data to to crunch the
German Wikipedia is the fourth largest
with over almost two million articles
all right so the thing is what can we
extract from Wikipedia that is going to
be similar to the type of time series
that we have from pricing data and how
can we relate that to so the first thing
that we can think of is okay I have an
article in Wikipedia now from this
article I can obtain a vector II
presentation and ideally I want for each
of my let's call them concepts or topics
for example in this case ducks or German
or stock market index
so for each relevant concept in
Wikipedia I want to come up with a
vectorized representation and this is
going to allow me to compare different
concepts between each other and then on
one hand I will have my my concepts that
I compare and we'll see in a minute how
we are going to compare them and on the
other hand I have the pricing data so
first thing to keep in mind a vectorized
representation out of the Wikipedia
article how do we obtain that well I
think this there's been a lot of talks
around the world to Veck models I'm not
gonna I'm not going to tell you a lot
out it just for those who haven't heard
about it before it's a model that was
not necessarily developed by McAuliffe
but he enabled it to scale to be able to
process data sets the size of Wikipedia
it everything starts in an LP and in
this case the same with the
distributional hypothesis that the
context of the world is very very
important in order to determine meaning
this model is is a very shallow neural
network to lay our neural network and
the idea is that you want to learn this
vector representation in order to
predict the context in order to predict
nearby words okay there's two two
flavors of this model so you have the
Skip Graham model and the Sybil model
continuous bag of words and the skipper
and they are basically mirrored so in
one case you start in the input layer
with your current word and your output
is going to be the context so this is
word at position t minus 2 where the
position t minus 1 and then the towards
after my current word WT whereas in the
continuous bag of words model we aim for
the opposite the input is our context
and the output is our is our word
okay now the word to vac model is going
to give us representations for the words
in Wikipedia however we don't need
representations for the words we need
two presentations for the topics now
let's say stock market index that's a
three word concept so how we are going
to be able to obtain that well the trick
is to assign
the an ID in this case we are going to
assign an ID obtained from the dbpedia
knowledgebase and we are going to
replace each concept so for example the
darks the blue-chip
and the stock market index we are going
to replace them in tax by their IDs and
by this we are going to be able to
obtain a vectorized representation using
using work of the words but also of this
concept that contain multiple words if
you want to know more about this
technique it's called wiki to that and
here is the repository which contains
the code and then in order to obtain our
similarity what we are going to do is we
are going to apply cosine similarity so
we have our concept here let's go check
bank and BMW and we're going to compute
cosine similarity between these two
concepts now that we have the vectorizer
presentation everything straightforward
so far the other way of looking at
Wikipedia is let's let's assume that
Wikipedia from Wikipedia we can
construct a big graph now we are gonna
have our concepts as not oops there we
go we're gonna have our concepts that's
not and these nodes are gonna be
interlinked so what kind of nodes can we
have well we can have the articles and
we can also have the categories and then
for the links there's quite a variety
that we can choose from so we can have
hyperlinks from article to article then
we can have also links from between
articles based on information in the
info box we can also have links between
articles and categories and we can also
have links between categories so let me
just show you
what I mean by this so in the Wikipedia
article we have all our links that point
from the concept ducks to quite a lot of
other other concepts then we also have
the category list so this tells us okay
ducks companies related to ducks are
added as aliens bears F and so on and we
also have the info box information so
again we get information sometimes
duplicate information that we would have
also found in the article about
relations between ducks and other
example operator exchange and so on good
okay so now that we have our graph
representation we know which are the
nodes which are the edges in order to
get the similarity between two concepts
what we can do is two things for example
there can be other approaches as well
one simple way of looking at this is to
use the distance between two the nodes
and then to say okay I can get a
similarity between my two nodes v1 and
v2 based on the distance so I just say
the similarity is 1 minus the distance
and the distance I can apply any better
for example super simple shortest path
in the graph another way of looking at
this is to use random walks in the graph
you can use vanilla PageRank for that or
if you want something that's a bit more
tailored because you know that some
nodes are more important as opposed to
others you can also use a personalized
PageRank and tweak the weights of the
nodes good so now coming to our our
analysis what we did is we took the 30
companies part of the tax index and for
each company we had information like its
sector ticker symbol index weighing and
number
employees and we used Janssen in order
to construct our work to that model and
we also used it in order to compute the
similarity between the companies so for
each company pair we obtain our worth of
X molarity okay next comes the pricing
data so let me just ask how many of you
are familiar with analysis of financial
data few of you okay for the rest I'll
go a bit more in detail so okay for a
company we get various pieces of
information so open means the open price
high low price close price volume and an
adjusted close this adjusted closed e so
close is when the stock market closes
that's the the final price for the day
and these are daily prices so end of day
prices and the adjusted closed is let's
say that a company let's say that the
shares split there's some restructuring
within the company then the justif close
price is going to reflect this kind of
changes within the company because
otherwise if you would take the close
price only then we are gonna see some
big jumps from high values to lower
values or vice versa depending on what
happens with the company and how the
price is gonna reflect these changes
good so this is our pricing data and
then we can use pandas data reader in
order to get the pricing data for each
of our companies and we can also tell it
when how far back in time we want to get
this data from okay next we need to
obtain daily returns for each of the
ducks camp
now why do we need daily returns because
if we would take the the pricing data as
such this pricing data you see that it
has it has a trend is not a stationary
process it's that it's mean and variance
it it changes over time in its settings
it increases over time as we've seen in
the in the first first slides so what we
need to do is we need to compute these
daily returns means that we are gonna
take the close price of today and we are
going going to take the close price of
yesterday and compute a difference and
we can do it in a simple way like here
or that log difference depends on the
analysis that we want to perform good
now once we have all this information we
can compute a correlation for each of
our possible pairs so you have companies
both companies we have our similarity
and we also have our correlation great
so the million-dollar question does
Wikipedia similarity explain the
correlation of returns any clues no
clues whatsoever no it doesn't ok ok
let's let's do this how many of you say
yes and how many say no what one doesn't
count because because who knows why so
we have we have two yes because he saw
the talk before but however this is this
is this is a Dax is not the footsie
index ok so so we have two people saying
yes and the rest say no ok good
so then now twin so far so what happened
is that based on the scatterplot and
based on
r-square we get some really nasty
results any idea why this happened so
what was the problem here but there's
something there's something in
particular about this scatter plot that
is that should give us we should not be
satisfied with this scatter plot let's
say like that exactly there there
there's these there are these data
points that don't really make sense so
any idea what what might be the cause of
such such behavior comparators countries
that's a it's a it's not really that
it's one problem which is called
Commerzbank
so it turns out that comments bank did
something very nasty in 2013 also what
it did is it did a reverse stock split
that means that the price the price
changed a lot and this change in price
because we were not we were taking the
the clothes prices this change in price
affected our our analysis so you see
that here it here as a result the
outstanding shirts were reduced to
around this amount 500 million shares
from 5.8 billion no with the price
multiplied by 10 so this greatly
affected greatly affected the price data
and just for us to to double check now
if we remove these these Commerce Park
outlier we do get
are two of 0.2 which is something that
we want to get okay so still now we
cannot remove outliers just like that
what could we do about it so is it
possible to to nevertheless be able to
to get meaningful results based on this
data remember that at the beginning I
was telling you about this adjusted
clause that takes into account this kind
of changes in price so if you look at
the adjusted clause and use adjusted
Clause returns your r2 is going to make
sense in this case because it
incorporates it incorporates these
changes in data and yeah so what this
talk and also previous analysis on the
footsie data said show is that you can
use Wikipedia or probably even other
unconventional data set in order to see
if unstructured data is of any help for
for determining correlations or even for
making predictions there's I was showing
you only what was working and what where
I did obtain results I was not telling
you where I didn't talk to any results
so it turned out that I was also trying
with graph based approach that I was
that I was explaining to you and the
thing there is that graph based
similarity does not capture very well
the similarity within a specific domain
so you are looking at companies that are
all within that are all in the Ducks
index so by default they are very
related because all of them are part of
the index lots of them are traded on the
Frankfurt Stock Exchange and this kind
of information made it that these
companies are all there
with each other and therefore there was
no correlation so I noted here
categories are too broad No so if this
category information is too broad
there's very little that we can we can
very little information that we can pull
out
however the context based the similarity
using word to vac proved to be a
powerful and robust measure and we could
we could actually capture similarity
using this this method however this is
this is a toy example so of course if
you are going to use datasets that are
particularly tailored for finance let's
say specific reports or much better
quality data then we expect to get much
better results okay so just a few
applications so one thing would be well
the obvious application is to make
predictions and another thing is not
only to use on structured data but also
to use a combination of unstructured
data and pricing data or other kinds of
quantitative data are the kinds of time
series data and see where one can can
help the other you can also use it for
estimating the other financial figures
ratios other statistical moments
particularly for this case you are
interested in the time preceding an IPO
because then we have very little
information or maybe not at all about
what price is a certain company gonna be
listed at so this turns out to be very
useful here are the resources that I've
used there's a notebook that's covering
this presentation you're you're also
going to find they're similar analysis
that I've done on on the footsie dataset
and the presentation that I did in
London at PI data then there's all the
word Tuvok and wiki Tuvok resources that
I've used
and related papers on on graph de
similarity good so thank you and if you
have any questions okay okay so the
question is how can we evaluate this
what does these are two of zero point to
tell us is this a big number is it a
small number what are we gonna expect so
the thing is that we are gonna X we
first of all we we don't expect that
these are highly correlated there's so
much information that Wikipedia that
that is encoding in Wikipedia that can
explain the stock price and this is
these are two shows us that there is
definitely signal because if there would
be zero signal they are two would be
zero okay and it's more quantifying how
much signal can I pull out of Wikipedia
how much correlation can I explain only
looking at Wikipedia data and this is
this fraction I would say a reasonable
amount a reasonable number is 0.2 0.3 I
don't expect to see numbers like 1 now I
don't expect to see perfect correlation
also because this is not a data set that
was built having in mind that you are
gonna be able to neither predict
anything there's no or there's very
little predicting power or there's very
little know that the the reason why
Wikipedia was created was not to Anna
as financial data the point that I want
to make is that even if you look at data
sets that are completely that are
created with completely different
purposes in mind still this should not
be disregarded unstructured data should
not be disregarded because there is
signal in unstructured data and the
signal should not only come from pricing
data for correlative data this is the
point
okay so the question was Google this is
Google where Tyvek is Google's
proprietary algorithm let's say am I not
afraid that if I do analysis and I use
Google's proprietary algorithms at some
point Google are gonna come knocking at
my door and say hey wait a second
so this is a toy example and this is a
demonstration for people for making
people aware that there's more there's
more information out there and oops
sorry there's more information out there
and there's more interesting things that
we should we should pay attention to if
I would want to come up with an
algorithm and I would want to start
trading then no you're right I wouldn't
use proprietary algorithms what I would
do is most likely I will anyways need to
come up with a specifically tailored
algorithm to my problem and it's not
going to be a vanilla where Tyvek
already the process that I will go when
extracting the data from let's say if I
take Wikipedia it's not going to be
taking something already existing out
there a pre-trained model and then
compute similarities and there you go i
get i get my correlations and from there
i can come up with a predictive model
that there is no free lunch so there is
not gonna not taking the code from this
presentation and running it on models
that google pre-trained or know somebody
as pre-trained is not gonna be the holy
grail of
yeah
so the model is is a very simple model
there's I would say that if if at all
you would use it as a baseline you would
say okay using this kind of model this
is these are the results that I can come
up with and then you can build on top of
that and your extensions and your
algorithm that is going to be
specifically tailored to your problem is
going to be quite quite different from
from where to Veck yeah don't know if
that answers your question
okay let me see how to summarize your
question so you are saying that the the
way that I'm doing my analysis is not
necessarily appropriate because
information that is in the stock in the
price is also reflected in Wikipedia
articles after a certain point in time
now that is the question so how to how
to take that into account well first of
all is not really the case that
information in Wikipedia the information
in Wikipedia information that you have
in the stock price is it really is there
is really a one-to-one relationship
because as I said Wikipedia you have
completely different it's built for
completely different purposes so you
will have in there lots of things around
I don't know
conflict if you take for example the
false waggon article about all the
scandals that they are having with
emissions and you're going to have a lot
of but it's gonna be it's gonna be very
descriptive it's gonna be a lot of
conflicting information and that from
that to be able to derive something that
is meaningful in terms of the price is
already pretty hard so if I take now if
I take a word to that model this model
is gonna show me a very shallow kind of
similarity and mainly it's gonna show me
that these two companies share the same
sector they
similar products and so on and that's
some generic information the generic
information that's available out there
and moreover this is intended that if
you don't have any information about a
particular company only text information
you don't have any price information are
you able to use this text information or
you should you just discard it again I
am not making any prediction here this
is not a predictive model this the the
goal of this talk is not to show that
there is predictive power the goal of
this talk is to show that there is
correlation between emka pedia and
pricing data it's not a pretty not
building a predictive model because
first of all because of his point not
because if you are if you want to build
a predictive model then the setup has to
be completely different second of all
because this predictive model will be
pretty poor because there is very little
information so there is not that there
is no information but still there's
little information that you can extract
from Wikipedia so you have to combine it
with something else you need to you will
still need some some different source
that is that's gonna give you that extra
piece of information otherwise you're
not gonna perform really well no yeah
measure of similarity they could just
give you another benchmark to compare
the point to versus no but I would be
happy to talk about this okay so the
question was if I was considering any
other kind of similarity or if I was
looking at particular within sector
similarity things like that